the world is just going to hell the
world's just freezing over like I I I
really think this is the end of times
because um not only not only is Adam 22
going mad we have Jada Smith
embarrassing Will Smith now guys a
couple times of a crazy lady one is J
picket Smith not taking Will Smith's
last name a lot of feminists will do the
the two last name thing where it's like
why why don't you want to belong to your
husband why do you want to belong to
yourself Andrew that doesn't really
doesn't really make sense to me so as
you guys may or may not know Jada has
really embarrassed Will Smith Will Smith
and Jada picket Smith were like the
couple of the century everybody loved
them they talked about how amazing they
were how awesome they were and there
were all these clips in the early 2000s
of them really being put on a pedestal
as a couple now guys I remember I had
this conversation with my mother before
any of the entanglement stuff came out I
said there is something wrong in that
family and my mom my mom said no she
said no they're cute whatever I said no
no no something is off something is off
because their kids are messed up because
I saw a video of Willow Smith talking
about how she was in an open
relationship and I remember she was like
18 19 at the time and I thought where
the hell did she get these ideas there's
no way in hell that I would have ever
thought to be in an open relationship I
wouldn't even know what that was and
later it comes out that Will and Jada
were in an open relationship H it makes
sense but anyways I called this I called
this before anybody now Jada is
basically going on a tour for her new
book and on this tour Jada reveals that
Tupac proposed to her while he was in
jail let's pull it up a lot of people
might not know but he proposed to you
while he was in jail I talk about this
in the book when I go to see him and
Rikers when I wrote about that in the
book and when I had to
um talk about it uh speak my words for
the audible version of the book that was
probably one of the more painful Parts
seeing him
there the condition that he was in and
having to leave him there and um he was
in he was he was in a he was he was he
was in bad
shape and so when he asked me to get
married he was at Riker
and I knew at that time that a he needed
somebody to doe time with him which I
was gon to do anyway you didn't have to
marry me to do time right I'm I'm here I
see why we love
you and then to um like he needed a rock
can you imagine being married to a woman
for 20 plus years and she's still
talking about her High School boyfriend
now J alleges they never hooked up or
anything but even if it was just an
emotional thing like J it's been 20 plus
years it's been 20 plus years and it's
so bad to the point that her daughter is
talking about how she misses Tupac and
even Will Smith admitted that at one
point he was jealous of their
relationship can you imagine a man
that's been gone for how long and you
know there's more to this interview so I
wanted to pull up another clip he needed
uh because of our friendship and because
of everything we have been through
together he just
wanted to feel that solidified
Foundation you know cuz I promise you he
would have married me and divorced me as
soon as his ass down he would right I be
real with it right cuz so many people in
that position don't have support right
none at all none you know and got right
he was just like
look and I just think it was the Mind
state that he was in you know he he
wrote me this long
letter and um I think even before Pac
went to jail he was starting to Trend he
was starting to shift in a certain
manner good or bad
good really good so guys again this is
why men pass up on women that have dated
bad boys in the past because a lot of
times the men of the future cannot live
up to the drama and excitement they got
out of those toxic relationships now she
claims they never hooked up I doubt it
but let's let's just assume she's
telling the truth and they never hooked
up that means this is the type of guy
that can put a woman in the friend zone
yes that those guys do exist and they
will put women in the friend zone now
she's in the position where will the
standup family man will never live up to
the bad boy that she never got and she
never could get so if you guys don't
remember last year will B Smith went
viral for slapping Chris Rock at the
Oscars Chris Rock made a joke about Jada
and you know will just got super mad and
then went up and slapped him for
it oh
wow wow Will Smith just smacked the [__]
out of me so fast forward to 2023 J
picket Smith says she was surprised will
referred to her as wife at the Oscars we
have been separated for 6 years let's
pull it up now first of
all I'm really shocked cuz mind you I'm
not there we haven't called each other
husband and wife yeah in a long time I'm
like what is going on right now name out
of your mouth right and I'm like but now
I'm really worried for will CU I don't
know what's going
on essentially Will and Jada were going
on all these talk shows talking about a
happily married they were giving this
presentation to the world that they were
happily married and really I would argue
that this is fraud how many people
modeled their relationship after them
not knowing how crazy it really was and
it's funny because in the red pill this
has been known they have known that Jada
was nuts for years they've predicted
this and and there's telltale signs that
you can really pick up in relationships
to see who's leading it and typically if
the woman's leading it we just lead
things to destruction so one sign is
that the wife doesn't take the husband's
last name um another sign is that they
refer to it as a partnership they didn't
do it there but that's a common one
another one is who speaks first when the
couple is asked a question who's
generally the center of attention when
they're talking to a couple does the
woman feel like she needs to ask for
permission from her husband to do things
go places or make family decisions and
you'll see that Jada and will over the
years have
displayed many many of those warning
signs but you really wouldn't know
unless you're in the red pill so let's
pull up this old clip of J Pull It Up
the only person that can give permission
is myself yes exactly yeah the only
person who can give permission to [__]
my [__] is me and will goes yeah yeah
so she's your wife you don't have any
control over who [__] her that's how
you view your relationship will yeah I'm
the only one who tells with [__] to
[__] my [__] oh yeah yeah baby yeah oh
yeah someone rallied your wife for 4
years what's your issue you're childish
it all started with him just needing
some help you notice what she did there
she started the store and she put
herself in a position of moral High
Ground no I was looking for dick we
became friends he needed help so being
the great nice person you can't get mad
at her for helping him that would be
terrible he needed some help and I
thought if I give him a [__] maybe do
you know how many people I've helped
without [__] that's what my reply
would be cuz I held the door open for
the [__] cameraman I suck his dick so
we can help loads of people without
[__] nobody po you know I might have
to end this T speech I don't know how
much longer I can do this yeah baby we
all came sick and you wanted to help him
as a let me calm
down see okay one I wanted to point out
how Jada says she doesn't need
permission and while this situation was
crazy her sleeping with another dude
that mindset typically translates I
don't need permission from you to tell
me what to wear I don't need permission
from you to tell me what to talk about
or where to go uh that mentality does
not work in relationships it does not
happy wife happy life leads to
destruction I mean look at this
craziness um and Andrew Tate is right he
is absolutely
right Will Smith is a successful
handsome rich guy that is absolutely a
beta so people have asked me for the
definition of a beta and I really I came
to a conclusion betas are men that
follow women yes that follow what women
want while men submit to the authority
of stronger men or to God betas submit
to the authority of women and
unfortunately even though Will Smith is
extremely talented he is beta I mean I
don't know what is a more beta thing you
can do than loan your wife out I mean
that's that's crazy so the comment
section weighed in Will Smith once
seemed like an example to follow now
he's an example of what to avoid uh
another comment says will is the biggest
simp in the world um
yos for twizzle says Jada is a walking
bald L Boer prash I thought Will Smith
was a powerful person but TC Libra she's
also the only one who decides who FS
Wills [__]
to
wow
um yeah uh yeah and and and this shows
how women ruin Empires the wrong woman
can absolutely not only destroy a guy's
life but destroy a gu's Empire and guys
it is better for men to be alone than to
be with women like this and I don't
remember what verse please Bible people
help me because I don't I don't remember
but there is there is a verse in the
Bible that talks about how a man is
better to be alone than to be with a
quarrelsome wife and if this situation
doesn't show that I don't know what will
Will Smith would be better off alone
than to be in this situation